money monster is directed by Jodie
Foster and stars George Clooney Julia
Roberts and jack oconnell George Clooney
plays a TV analyst he's one of those
really loud boisterous people who talks
about the stock market makes it very
entertaining he does dancer teens with
girls and everything and he gets held at
gunpoint by Jack O'Connell who has a
grudge against him for a reason I'm not
going to divulge Julia Roberts plays the
director of this show who's in the booth
talking to George Clooney through an
earpiece instructing him on the best way
to handle this extremely delicate
situation so at its core money monster
is a thriller it's a suspenseful
white-knuckled contained thriller and
that's when this movie works the best
when you're in that newsroom with George
Clooney at gunpoint Jack O'Connell
screaming in his ear Julia Roberts
trying to calm down a situation that's
where this movie works the best and
that's where I had a ton of fun with
money monster and was actually
surprisingly really invested in its
story unfortunately the movie also goes
out of this newsroom quite often to
what's going on outside of the newsroom
on Wall Street this is integral to the
plot of the movie but the way they
handle it is quite often you just go
somewhere else with characters you don't
really care that much about and the film
loses its steam during those time
periods for me the newsroom where this
suspenseful situation is going on this
contained scary situation was where this
film was most thrilling for me and the
performances are all uniformly excellent
George Clooney as usual is very very
good here as is Jack O'Connell as this
guy who is just tortured by not only his
personal life but a very bad decision he
made and you can kind of see that his
life has really been a downward spiral
of a lot of bad decisions similar to
that one and so you can kind of feel for
his character and understand where he's
coming from
even though you don't necessarily
condone what he's doing his motivations
are clear and you understand why he's
there and for that reason as an
antagonist you actually kind of start to
care about him and that's also a really
good strength of this film because you
see the human behind the act that he's
committing and you really understand
what has brought him to this point Julia
Roberts is also really good these are
all things that you probably heard a
thousand times George Clooney is good
yes Julia Roberts is very good
this film you know what am I saying
that's new but what can I say she is
she's really good in this movie she's
the calm voice in the storm she's the
one who's trying to make everything go
smoothly she's used to dealing with a
very hectic newsroom this character and
so this situation is almost strangely
familiar for her and the fact that we
are able to realize that much about her
character just by watching this film and
that tells you that the
characterizations are pretty good at
least with the three leads whenever the
film goes outside of the newsroom and
tries to tell its corporate Wall Street
story in which it's very much so bashing
Wall Street
whenever the film gets a little more
preachy than you would expect it to be
that's where the film doesn't really
reach the dramatic Heights it's trying
to has it contained suspenseful thriller
it really works but sometimes it does
overstep its boundaries and try to have
a message one of the biggest messages is
how the world now reacts to horrible
situations through the internet which in
turn provides some of the movies best
humor because it also has good humor
about the subject one scene involving
vine I'm not going to spoil it but it
was pretty laughs I'd love larious the
performances are all excellent and the
stuff inside the newsroom is really
riveting but whenever they go outside of
it the movie loses a little bit of steam
I'm gonna give money monster of B I
think Jodie Foster did a surprisingly
good job directing this movie she's made
a lot of smaller films this is her first
attempt at a larger film if you've never
seen the beaver I actually think it's a
very underrated movie and I suggest
checking that out she did a very good
job of that one also it's got a great
performance by Mel Gibson Jennifer
Lawrence Antoine Yelchin and Jodie
Foster guys I got something really cool
I want to tell you about a giveaway that
I'm running right now first off thank
you so much to everyone who bought my
book it really means the world to me I
worked for about a year on this and it
was tons of fun to write the publishers
mango media key lime press are actually
going to be hosting this giveaway for
anyone who purchases the book from now
to may 22nd on Amazon can be entered to
win a prize that the publishers are
going to eventually deem and announce as
a collaboration between myself and the
guys at comics Torian because they're
also writing a book very soon that's
going to be coming out about comic book
movies that I wrote the foreword for and
these guys are awesome they're extremely
knowledgeable they're very talented they
make great content and I'm humbled by
the fact that I got to work with them
even ever so briefly so that giveaway
taking place on Amazon you can enter for
a price by just purchasing copy of the
book from now until May 22nd all you
have to do is send an email to info at
mango dot biz with the subject line
stuckman in the header and your email
confirmation number of your order and
that's the giveaway guys thank you so
much again for reading my book I really
do appreciate it it meant a lot to me
you guys are the best and I hope you
check out money monster because it is
surprisingly better than I thought it
was going to be thanks so much as always
for watching guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes